Joe Biden got a bunch of surgery he got
plastic surgery got his hair done it's
really disturbing Hillary he's falling
apart he's got plates in his brain he
can barely talk it's like he's just he's
just losing what is this a placeholder
is that what you think yeah that that
was um what magazine was it Atlantic oh
yeah 2020 election they said time wasn't
it with the no no no no Atlantic said
stay alive Joe Biden all you need is
your corporeal form yeah they were
outright saying we just need a guy who
can get votes but for four years it was
pretty clear during the Trump presidency
that the president has far less Powers
than we are told and it was a complaint
of his that it's like the government's
running itself and I'm not they're
they're bragging about how they kind of
you know did enrance about him and the
Press was cheering it on like especially
with the like oh what do you mean the
cheering on the idea that for the first
time in my lifetime the president had
his authority rescinded and revoked now
there's there's bad things to that in
terms of what Trump want to do like
ending War